[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
naturel il joue pas un rôle là il est
dedans
complètement très bien merci merci pour
ce témoignage poignant à prochainement
ya surtout visible candelo wang avec
succès on les retrouve tous les
vendredis à 20h45 sur du lit dans les
phases in-game à la neige alors je vais
demander ou que vous ne vous connaissiez
pas bon lorsque les cépages et la chaîne
qui vous a réuni vous avez tout de suite
dit oui pour travailler avec philippe
anne-gaëlle non j'ai longuement réfléchi
et puis après bon l'appât du gain j'ai
vraiment se marier contre l'argent vous
montez et donc j'ai fini par dire oui
non mais moi je ne suis pas du tout posé
la question est ce qu'il est ou a besoin
de se priver mais juste l'appât du gain
non c'est l'appât d'un gain un gars qui
n'est pas désagréable expliqué toujours
comme ça c'est à dire toujours comme ça
sert même hors caméra tout ça est ce
qu'il est toujours comme chantiers à
venir des blagounettes alloway il aime
bien les blacks boon est effectivement
non mais il est tel qu'on l'imaginé
quand on voit à l'antenne comme ça on
voit là on voit un mec sympathique
plutôt déconneur et voilà dégâts
l'humeur ça doit faire un vrai plaisir
il le dit lui même il est très près de
ses sous philippe vous à payer un truc
pendant les tournages même pas un vin
chaud quand même pas s est même pas mal
pour être de petites souvent après de
vos soupes ou fait tout pour pour
pourrait rejouer duncan ont mis un soin
c'est un cadeau de ce soir je vais vous
dire philippe candeloro a fait quelque
chose pour vous
[Applaudissements]
bouquet de fleurs
payées demain
[Rires]